edward snowden hitchhiking tempted to
pandora's box or two and sms code hand
in the cookie joe de je kees name of
self breasting spotted my publications
and baby operating and a new jersey girl
listening post van de msm gel en in
brussels and epc is time  for europe
happiness and so a pack of the bios' fields
and oversight and range man here in
that not something here philippa we were
no child rather olivia sting and
medication to living situation families in
national governments a cruise red
lions in napa seat of national security
and  not surprised about intelligence
services tension of doing secret things
but am very surprised at goverment see
i think that's the other member states
of its citizens are set to national
security
agency he is already taking place de
planner in five suspend in  the swift
agreement should here was brought 5
december liberty's inquiries pensionaat
de plague in a record how the free trade
agreement with us forest  and bottom the
bee for this more and more you rejoice
lc camp the food and pigeons
two dbf ink tanks an academic beginning
at frank-ly at weather and her his
wheel cici
marches willy yes pie dns just what is
so bni partnership with that he doesn't  had
my be went out of his eye search of
other she's like free shampoo and what
this is pro pro adornment and capability
of intelligence services of individual
here concrete and bulbs am the man
behind revelations he must cut into
many of the secrets of edward snowden or
when  i have been a new york where of
course you would like to do so get some
personal die ditto crash en hem wat
this seems to be at the moment big
problem of the security questions and
the
legal questions behind his patches en zo
snow to be on  set by the governments
as the yippee member states